All right. Uh we'll get started. Um
sorry I uh the lecture slides for this
lecture was not up uh earlier today, but
um it is now up. So, if you want to have
that at your fingertips to look at, um
you should be able to get it through
uh the course website. Um but if not,
you can it's definitely up there on the
uh GitHub. Today, we're going to talk
about um what I think of as kind of like
more advanced uh architecture ideas. Um
so, last lecture was really about the
basic transformer and how, you know, we
might tweak different parts of the basic
transformer to get to a modern language
model.
Um now, I want to talk about things that
I think are much more advanced, much
more complex uh developments on top of
the usual transformer. And the two
things I'll talk about uh today, the
first one is um attentional
alternatives, ways of going to much
longer contexts using architectural
changes
that for the most part generally allow
for linear time dependence um on the
length of the sequence rather than
quadratic.
Um the second thing I want to talk about
is the idea of mixture of experts,
right? So, the first part is, you know,
modifying the attention block. The
second part is going to be modifying the
uh MLP part, right? And mixture of
experts are going to give us
significantly better utilization um in
terms of our hardware, in terms of
having more parameters um relative to
the compute that we have to spend on
these models. So, those are the two
parts and the two ideas um for today.
So, I'm going to start with attention
and I'm going to set the stage. Um it's
clear now that people want longer
context length, right? You want to pack
a lot of things into the context so that
your model has more knowledge, maybe
it's an agent that operates on lots of
things. If you look at, you know,
different models over time on the x-axis
over here and you know, the context
window size, this is in log scale, you
know, there's really a clear rush by a
lot of the the top LM vendors to provide
larger and larger context sizes to
support these kinds of, you know, more
complex workloads.
Now, how do we control these costs?
Well, you know, um
all right, oh not not yet. Um the right
plot also shows, you know, the ratio
between, you know, how much compute cost
is spent in the feed forward part of the
network versus the attention part of the
network as you increase the sequence
lengths. Um and you see that, you know,
the feed forward fairly large at the
start, um but grows linearly. Attention,
right, is an all-to-all connection
between all the different positions,
quadratic, so quickly outpaces feed
forward um as the sequence length grows,
right? So, um you know, it used to be
that for big models at like smallish
sequence lengths, feed forward was the
dominant cost. As you go to these longer
sequence lengths, attention increasingly
becomes um more and more of a problem,
right?
Now, what's kind of the basic toolkit by
which we can control these? And we've
already talked about these, or well, we
talked about one of these and we will
talk about another one of these. Um you
know, we can basically take things like
local attention um and combine them in
different kinds of hybrid ways to
control the very high cost of global
attention, right? Um if you're only
doing global attention once every eight
layers and all the other ones are these
like very local attentions, you've very
much controlled the cost.
The other thing you can do is systems
engineering. Um
I think what very underappreciated fact
is, you know, constant factors really,
really matter, right? Part of the theme
of this course is you need to pay
attention to the details and it's very
easy for people trained in like a more
classical theory-oriented computer
science tradition to be like, "Oh, yes,
it's the big O that matters, right?
Linear or quadratic."
Um but I think one of the biggest things
that has happened to, you know, contexts
and like attention cost is flash
attention, right? Flash attention, we'll
talk about this in a lot more detail
once we get to the systems lecture and
as you do the systems assignments, but
flash attention is really just a very
clever way of rearranging the um
attention operation into a much more
systems-friendly way to minimize uh
memory sort of transfer overhead.
And by doing so, you can get truly,
truly dramatic improvements in uh the
performance of your attention. So, you
know, base PyTorch is this blue, you
know, you can just kind of look at some
of the shorter sequence lengths, you're
doing like 30 to 40 um op uh flops per
sec, a teraflops per second. Um and then
you do flash attention, which is really
a constant factor systems improvement,
and you're getting these big, big
improvements like factors of two
improvements. And at some sizes, you
can't even fit this in memory anymore,
but with flash attention, where you're
not materializing these big attention
matrices anymore, you can continue to
run these, albeit, you know, somewhat
slowly, right? This doesn't fix any of
the quadratic cost issues, but constant
factors are very, very powerful.
Now, that said, you know, if we're going
to to five, 10 million tokens, these
tricks might not be enough. We want much
more radical, much larger gains in our
ability to handle long contexts. So,
this leads us to the question, is there
ways for us to have linear time or
linear dependence on the length of the
sequence?
And what would those kinds of things um
look like?
Okay, there we go.
Um it turns out that, you know, a lot of
people have tried a lot of different
things over the years. Um and I think
there are a few false starts, um but in
the recent years, I would say the last
two-ish years, there's been kind of an
emergence of a a set of recipes that are
fairly effective in linear time
attention that are now kind of
battle-tested at scale. Um and that's
kind of why
uh this is finally the first year when
I'm, you know, talking about linear time
attention because it's it's clear now
that these things really work at scale
and in production and so on.
Um
to really
um explain all of these different
methods that work well, I think you need
to really only understand one core idea
to start with and then we're going to
elaborate and build upon that idea.
Um and that idea to start with is the
associativity
um of multiplication. So, let's think
about how attention works. Um we can
write it in this compact notation where
we say, you know, the the attention
operation is going to be have Qs, Ks,
and Vs, right, with these, you know,
matrix dimensions up here.
Um and you know, I'm going to take my Qs
and the Ks and I'm going to have a
all-to-all interaction, right? All the N
positions are going to interact with
each other by matrix multiplication. And
then I'll normalize them through a
softmax, this this row over here, and
then I will multiply it with my my my
values V to get the attention outputs,
right? This is a classic, you know,
self-attention or whatever other
attention
uh operation.
Now, you know, for the moment, let's
forget that, you know, attention has a
softmax and then I'm just going to drop
the row, like forget it for the moment,
right?
Now, if we didn't have a row, maybe we
can actually change the complexity of
this operation. So, you know, if you
look at attention, it's, you know, N
squared DK, right? Because we're taking
this QK transpose multiplication.
But if row was the identity, I can just
move the parentheses around a little bit
and I can say, all right, instead of,
you know, QK transpose V, really I'm
going to have what I'm going to have is
Q K transpose V, right? And if we do
this reordering, um well, we've like
changed which part is quadratic, right?
Like instead of having the N squareds,
which were pretty terrible because these
Ns are very big, they're millions,
right? That's the context length.
Um instead, I can have dependence on uh
NDVD K, right? So, now we're multiplying
um essentially the key and the value
dimensions. These could be big in
principle, right? I can have a big
model, but these are usually on the
order of like thousands, tens of
thousands, right? No one has like a a
million coordinates in their
uh in their hidden uh dimensions.
And so, you know, this is a much more
favorable uh sort of, you know, uh term
to be dependent on compared to this N
squared term when we were, you know,
doing this original attention operation,
right? So, this is the first thing that
you should know, which is like
associativity of multiplication allows
us to change kind of the the dependence
on the sequence length.
Okay.
Um now,
the other thing that we can do now is,
you know, if we consider this
reordering, this like QK transpose V,
um
something that's even nicer about this,
and I think this has led to really a lot
of the research that, you know, I'm
going to mention in the next couple
slides, is that, you know, this matrix
multiply on the right in the
self-attention case looks just like an
RNN, right? Instead of writing it in
this dense form up here, I can write it
incrementally as I sweep left to right
on my context, you know, I can multiply
my Ks and Vs, right? And I can update
this thing S, which is a state, and I
can add it to my previous state. This is
kind of like incrementally multiplying
and accumulating my KVs, and I can
multiply it with my Q to get my output,
right? And this, you know, dense
operation up here and this RNN form, you
know, are kind of equivalent. And so,
you know, what have we done? Well, we've
started from linear attention on the top
left and then we've somehow gotten
something that looks very much like an
RNN. And what's nice about RNNs? Well,
RNNs are quite nice because at inference
time, right, I have this S, which is my
state, you know, it's fixed in size and
I'm just carrying that forward and
forward, right? So, RNNs are very nice
for inference reasons, um they are, you
know, not nice for training reasons, but
nice thing about linear attention is you
can use them in either way, right? You
can have it in this dense form, which
will be great for training, it's
parallel, or you can have it in this
sort of serial form like an RNN, which
is great for inference, right? So, you
can get the best of both worlds.
Now, um at least in terms of like
dependence of all these objects, this is
great, this is lovely. Um unfortunately,
this is linear, which is not very good.
Um
you know, this is really sort of the
starting point of our discussion. Um any
questions so far? This is really the
basics.
Okay.
Um
One cool thing is um there have been
people that have basically, uh um,
used this linear attention as part of
their, um,
of their attention mechanism. Um, so
Minimax M1, which is a fairly
large-scale, fairly high-performance
Chinese, um, open model, um, uses a 7:1
hybrid. So, seven, you know, linear
attention layers plus one full, uh,
softmax attention. Um, performance
generally strong. You can compare it to
a number of, you know, strong models
like, you know, Open as 03 or DeepSeek
R1, fairly competitive. And then, you
know, since it's linear attention, most
of the dependence on context length is
linear, you know, it's not fully linear
cuz you've got these softmaxes, but the
dependence is much, much milder, right?
Um,
so, you know, this is one example where
people have shown that this even this
basic linear attention, which is very,
very simple to understand, um, can be,
you know, used fairly effectively at
scale. As long as you've got some sort
of full, uh, quadratic connections, uh,
involved. Um, no one has thus far really
proven out, uh, fully linear time
attention mechanisms at scale. Uh,
everything that I'm going to talk about
in the next couple slides is a hybrid.
Okay.
So, now, you know, we've done linear
attention, but you might say, "Linear
attention's too naive and simple for me.
Like, this is not what I want. I want
some more like serious, complex,
um, neural network stuff to be
happening." Well, um, what you can now
do is, uh, oh, sorry. Went a little too
far.
Um, look at the RNN form of linear
attention. So, you know, I've put the
linear attention equation right here
just so you don't have to keep going
back and forth. Um, and we can add a a
small elaboration to, uh, linear
attention in order to get more
expressive updates. Um, and this is how
you end up getting Mamba 2. Um,
some of you may have heard of Mamba,
Mamba 2, Mamba 3 now, I think. Um, these
are a family of state space models, um,
by, uh, Albert Gu and Tri Dao and and
friends. Um, and, you know, they're
derived originally from like this kind
of state space theory and view, but
actually if you look at the mechanics
of, you know, what is being done, you
can actually see it as a very simple
elaboration of the linear attention
mechanism. And so, the idea is the
following, right? So, we start with
linear attention.
And you might say, "Really, the main
problem with linear attention is that
I'm always passing my state forward,
right?" We know from like the olden days
of LSTMs that it's important to know
when to pass information forward and
when to just not pass information
forward, right? To forget things and
send them to zero. So, what I'm going to
do is I'm going to be inspired by that,
and I'm going to add a gate gamma,
right? Gamma of T. Gamma of T is not
stateful. Gamma of T only depends on my
current inputs X of T. Um, and gamma of
T, um, is going to modulate how much of
my state I'm going to carry forward into
the future.
Now, if you think about this, you know,
the state-dependent terms are all these
S's. Um, this gamma is not
state-dependent at all. So, this means
that, you know, this is very simple to
compute, and there's still sort of this
duality. You can, uh, compute this Mamba
2 term either as a big dense matrix
multiply or at inference time use it in
this sort of recurrent form, um, to, um,
uh, get nice inference improvements,
right? So, that's kind of the core sort
of conceit or view of this idea that,
you know, you can either use them in
parallel or sequence just like linear
attention, um, and people have now used
this at scale. So, NeMo Tron 3, I
mentioned, uh, briefly last lecture,
um, uses this idea of combining Mamba 2
as their sort of lightweight layer, and
of course, you've got your big softmax
attention every now and then, um, and
they sort of alternate this in various
ways to to manage their inference cost
expressiveness trade-off.
Um,
NeMo Tron, um, NeMo Tron 3 achieves, you
know, pretty good performance compared
to Qwen 3, uh, thinking as compared to
GPT-OSS, um, and because of all these
Mamba 2 layers, you know, has pretty
good throughput at fairly large context
length. So, you know, you can see that
it kind of works. Uh, at least these are
small frontier models, not like really
big frontier models, but, you know,
small frontier models, uh, that are open
source.
Cool.
So, now we've like built on this gating
idea, which is cool.
You might say, though, like, "Can we
just, you know, keep pushing this idea
further and like taking this recurrence
and making it sort of increasingly more
complex?"
Um, and kind of the rule of thumb in
some sense for what you can do with your
operations here is, as long as you're
gating the various terms in your RNN, so
to speak, with only input-dependent
terms. So, no state dependence, then
you'll still have this fairly nice
duality between sort of parallel
operations, which you can use for
training, and serial operations, which,
you know, you are going to use for for
inference. So, Gated DeltaNet is
probably, uh, among the most
widely used, I would say, um, state
space model now. I think it's been
tested in quite a few papers,
um, and there's, you know, a very nice
sort of,
uh, large-scale scale-up, um, in Qwen 3,
sorry, 3.5 for these models. So, let me
talk you through what Gated DeltaNet is
um, in comparison to Mamba 2.
So, Mamba 2 is, you know, as I have at
this top here, we take the linear sort
of recurrence, this state update. And
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
gate it with my gamma, right? Oh, I
forgot to explain this VT. Sorry, I I
apologize for that. Um, I added this for
completeness. Mamba 2 also has a
modification where they add what is
basically a residual layer to the YT
update. It's not really core to sort of
the state update or their arguments for
why this is a good idea, but I put it in
for completeness just to make sure, um,
I'm actually giving the true Mamba 2,
uh, updates rather than sort of a more
abridged version. Um, that only gets the
idea score ideas across.
Okay. Um, but you can ignore the VT for
now. This is really just like a
architectural improvement that's not
core to the state updates.
Um, Gated DeltaNet takes this idea in
some sense, um, and adds a second gate,
beta T. So, what does beta T do? Um,
beta T I think of as a no input
operation gate, right? If beta T is
zero, that basically means don't take
any of my current information, don't add
it into my state, right? Um, and I think
most or all of you are probably familiar
with LSTMs, right? This is very
reminiscent of the ideas in LSTM. You've
got gates that control, you know,
whether to forget and whether to put in
information from the current time step,
right? So, they operate in a very
similar set of principles, um, although,
of course, derived, I think, originally
in a very different way.
Now, the other thing that's interesting
about, uh, Gated DeltaNet, and this
comes from the the DeltaNet rather than
the Gated DeltaNet, is this, um, update
direction. So, instead of just gating
things, you could have made this 1 minus
beta T, for example. Um, what they do is
if you're going to do an update where
you're putting in this beta, what you're
going to do is you're going to try to
project out in some sense my current key
direction. So, the intuition here is I'm
going to be writing in information from
my current key, K of T.
And when doing that, not only do I want
to put in new information, I also want
to erase any previous keys that have
gone into it, right? That's one way that
you can think about updates. Like, not
just put stuff in, you know, I want to
clear out the current key that has gone
in. And that's why there's this blue
term, this identity minus beta T KT KT
transpose, which is essentially acting
as a projector that is projecting out
things in the KT dimension.
That's not exactly right because you're
not doing things like unit
normalization, but, you know, you kind
of get roughly the the intuition here.
Um,
the other thing I'll mention before I
kind of move on, oops, sorry, I have
this blue box here. I'll I'll move on
with Gated DeltaNet is, um,
that this has been reinvented in some
ways in in various settings. Um, this
update, this projector appears if you
try to solve certain kinds of like
meta-learning least squares problems.
So, it's been reinvented, um, in other
forms in, uh, fast weight programming or
test time training, where essentially
through very different design
principles, um, researchers from those
areas have basically ended up, um, with
the exact same kinds of solutions.
Um,
and the thing that I'll say here is, you
know, the Qwen 3.5 and the Qwen Next
models that were kind of predecessors to
that, um, some of the best open source
models available today, um, and they use
exactly this this architecture. They use
a 3:1 Gated DeltaNet attention hybrid,
um, very good, very reasonable
performance, um, strong inference
characteristics that you can see on the
right there, you know, Qwen
uh, Next has like much higher decoding
throughput relative to Qwen 3 as the
context length goes up and up and up.
Um, the middle panel is a comparison of
performance versus various like close
source models and like previous
generation models, this hybrid
architecture doesn't seem to hurt
performance very much at all.
Um,
the last thing,
um, that I will say is, you know, there
hasn't been that many great sort of
controlled studies of how hybrid
architectures perform. Um, there's maybe
one by ByteDance seed and UC Santa Cruz
folks where they compare things like
Mamba 2 and Gated DeltaNet and other
architectures as a function of how many
sort of hybrid layers you have. Um, some
of the results I would say are kind of
messy, but, you know, the things that I
would point at is this dash line over
here on this right panel. This guy is
full attention performance, and as you
go from left to right, this is
increasing the number of sort of
non-full attention layers. So, you know,
the the RNN layers, let's call them. You
know, are you increasing them as you go
to the right, and you see performance
degradation.
But maybe the thing to to see here is
that for some of the best architectures
that you have, like the yellow, the
orange, the blue, um these are like the
gated delta nets and like various other
uh variants, you know, you see that at
the low ratios, there's basically no
hit. And then uh once you pass a certain
point, you start to see more significant
degradation in performance uh in long
context performance in this case. Um as
you basically at the end as you go to
full RNN, you know, you have very
noticeable performance degradation in
all these architectures. Um the same is
true at various different other kinds of
evaluations. Um some of these I think
have been optimized by um the
architectures themselves, like single
key retrieval is a task that I think all
of these uh long context architectures
explicitly optimize for, but if you look
at QA performance, we sort of see the
same story, that as we increase the
amount of hybrid ratio, you know, we see
decreases in performance fairly steadily
and fairly clearly, ending up at this
pure point.
Okay.
Um any questions for for the linear time
attention stuff? I have one last
efficient attention thing to to talk
about, but yes.
In the beginning, um you talked about
like the parallel form of attention
versus the linear form, like
there.
Not not not at all.
Shouldn't they be like approximately
equivalent to slightly
degradation in performance?
Sorry, by by recurrent I mean uh
you know, I I meant RNN in general, like
any recurrent formulation. So, gated
delta net would be a recurrence. Um that
is not equivalent to this top one. This
is full softmax attention with the row,
right? The first step is where we drop
the row and then we become linear,
right? That's the very very first step
of any of these. So, this part is going
to be lossy and then after that, you
know, this linear form to, you know,
this recurrent form, this equivalence,
that is exact.
Good.
Yes.
What's the
ET actual ET like the
attention term below?
Oh, oh, oh, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Um yeah, this term, right? Yeah. Um so,
in the linear um attention form, what
we're really doing is, you know, we're
taking these KVs and we're, you know, uh
accumulating them with Qs, right? In the
dual form, that's kind of how this
operates.
Um
but you might actually want in your
outputs to also have some value from
your current time step. You might think
that oh, the value for my current time
step for my token is actually useful for
various things downstream. And so, this
acts a little bit like a residual
connection, where the value of my
current inputs directly pass through to
the outputs of my attention. And D is,
you know, another modulated gate, where
you can control the amount of pass
through that happens.
Good. Okay.
So, that's linear time attention.
There's a lot of really interesting
stuff. Um it's kind of also interesting
that a lot of the methods that have
gotten, you know, tested out really have
this nice simple linear attention style
recurrent form. Um there's a few
exceptions, but for the most part, a lot
of this has converged to almost very
LSTM-like objects in the end.
Okay.
Um
What do you want to say? Uh right, okay.
So, there's another alternative. Um what
I talked about was linear attention,
which has this, you know, very nice like
complexity theoretic, you know, uh
flavor to it. Um I want to talk about
another uh attention optimization, which
I did not talk about, but falls into
this family of like efficient attention
things that are kind of important. Um
so, DeepSeek in DeepSeek 3.2, I think,
um had uh DSA, um not do sparse
attention, that's DeepSeek attention,
um where what they do is instead of um
computing attention Oh,
that was not intentional pun.
Um instead of computing attention over
all the tokens, what you're going to do
is you're going to first have a
lightweight indexer that's going to
subset a bunch of tokens, right? So,
you're going to look at your very long
context and the indexer is going to pick
out, you know, some subset of these, um
much smaller than the full sequence, and
then you're going to do full attention
on that smaller subset, right? Um
So, the mechanics of this are pretty
simple, at least in the forward pass.
Um where what you do is you have, you
know, your normal Qs and Ks, um but then
you pass this through this indexer. And
what the indexer does is it takes the QK
inner products, it takes a ReLU, um and
then it's going to uh have these weights
that are derived from the preceding
tokens, and then this is going to give
you um the act sort of the the
activations for um each of the
positions. And then you're going to pick
this through a top K, where some number
of these, you know, top positions get
sort of included into my attention
computation, and I'm going to do my
usual attention computation that emits a
key value.
Um the nice thing about this is it's
very very sparse, um and if this indexer
is lightweight, now this bottom term,
where you're doing full attention, can
be done on a very small subset. Another
thing that both uh DSA and I think um
GLM uh show is that you don't actually
have to train the model with this, cuz
training with this like indexer thing is
is maybe pretty annoying and very
complex. What you do is you just train a
normal transformer, and when you do your
long context extension, you actually
then drop in this lightning indexer, and
then you train the model to sort of
handle this indexer in a sort of
extension stage that's separate from
pre-training. So, actually the
computational cost of doing this is
itself pretty light.
Um and I want to highlight, you know, in
in DeepSeek's
V3.2, where they they proposed DSA, you
know, this model is quite good. Like
V3.2, you know, matches all of the other
um frontier models at the time, like
Claude 4.5 Sonnet or Gemini 3. Um and
they also have this very nice plot where
they're showing, well, you know, our our
prefill, which is like the attending to
the the input, um and also decoding,
where you're actually generating, both
of these are very sort of favorable
scaling compared to the previous
generation of DeepSeek models that did
not use sparse attention. And that kind
of makes sense, right? If you're only
paying attention to a very small subset,
you're going to dramatically be reducing
your costs of doing attention.
Um and I think another nice orthogonal
sort of validation of this is GLM 5, um
which um came out last year. Uh
I think GLM 5 is one of the
you know, the best open models that are
available, like period. Um and they also
adopted this DSA approach, and they have
actually fairly nice ablations in their
paper, if you're if you're curious,
where they end up sort of comparing with
like oh, what happens if we do DSA with
some warm-up or, you know, just do DSA
or don't do DSA at all, you know, the
main thing that they're showing is if
they do full DSA training,
um you know, you don't lose very much in
performance relative to full
attention, even at long context
retrieval tasks um that are fairly
difficult to to do with
RNN-style architectures. So, this is a
totally alternative view of how to
reduce
uh attention costs. Notice, I'll I'll go
back one slide, this is not linear time,
right? The indexer still has to operate
on full all-to-all attention, cuz you
got these QK inner products that are not
going to be linear in cost, but you can
make this indexer much much cheaper, um
for example, by making this lower
dimensional or making this W very small,
um all of this can be made, you know,
much cheaper in its cost, right?
Okay. Um so, that's a totally
alternative view, works very well. I
won't talk much about this, but it turns
out that this idea of top K selection is
going to be core to the next part uh of
this lecture. I'll stop here for for any
efficient attention questions before I
move on to uh MOEs.
Yes.
So,
uh the the indexer, the time complexity
for that, is it
It's quadratic. Quadratic, yeah. Yeah.
That's right. Cuz it has to I mean, in
order to know what to select, it does
have to look at everything, right? Okay.
And there's no clever like state
transition stuff that happens here. It
is really brute force inner products.
So, if you're going through all of it
and then like afterwards, the step
afterwards is also quadratic as well,
how are we getting
It's It's I mean, it's kind of like a
systems-y trick almost. Like you're
going to do the indexer much more
lightweight, and there are many ways to
do that. You can do that in much lower
precision, which they talk about. You
can do it in um ways that are lower
dimensional by projecting the Qs and Ks
further just for the indexing. So, there
are lots of tricks that you can do here
that you can imagine, but the indexer is
going to be much more lightweight, so
the constant factors are very good. And
then the for the second one, even though
it's quadratic, it's quadratic on a
shorter context length, cuz it's top K,
we can control K. So, now it's this is
expensive, but small, right? So, it's,
you know, this is another one of these
things of um
sometimes don't get too stuck up on the
quadratic quadratic versus not.
Sometimes the constant factors are
really really important.
There's another question? Yeah.
That's right.
That's right. That's right. Or it's part
of like a continued pre-training style
thing. Because all the models, you know,
you don't train long context from
scratch for compute and various other
reasons, you train a shortish context
model first, and then you've got these
long context extension stages. And so,
the nice idea here is that, you know,
we're going to do the second phase
anyway, why don't we bolt the long
context, you know, cost savings on at
the same stage, right? And it's kind of
surprising that it works, you know,
honestly, that you can bolt on this uh
frankly scary-looking top K
non-differentiable object, but as you'll
see in the next part, um maybe you
shouldn't be so scared of top K
selection.
in the process, so is this also part of
the post another post-training step?
Yeah, the usual recipe that I am
familiar with with a lot of the
open-source models is that usually goes
like short context pre-training, long
context extension, then post-training.
Yes. Is the K here similar in length to
the short context length?
Yeah, that's right. Like you would pick
values that are like much closer to
short context performance and you would
bound it, right? So, regardless of the
input size, they would be bound.
Okay, actually many questions. I
appreciate
Are there general tests for the removal
of the soft max
for the context length?
Training stability issues. That's a good
question.
Um, I don't think so. I'm not aware of
like,
you know, documented linear uh soft max
causing lots of attentions. If anything,
soft maxes are usually more of the
problems for various reasons.
Um, so I think this would actually
improve the stability properties of the
architecture.
Um, can you briefly could you briefly
describe
the next level of deep learning
attention?
a better a better attention method
mechanism because because of the uh the
uh the
low community cost and the low latency.
Yeah. Can you elaborate what do you
mean? Like what kind of Like the
highlight
in highlight of what highlight in the
future is
a better attention mechanism.
The the yeah, the vast majority of the
Yeah, I don't know if I have good
predictions for what the future
attention architecture looks like. I
mean, my somewhat cop-out answer to this
is I think a lot of this will look like
we throw all of these tricks in, right?
In the same ways that architectures have
gotten very complex by taking all of
these successful recipes and throwing
them in. I think also that there's a a
even
uh broader layer or like a higher level
layer of basically using post-training
to to have the model manage its own
context, right? Compaction, retrieval,
all of these things are basically an
added layer on top. Um, I think a lot of
the the work that I imagine will be
integration of these different layers
because we've seen that, you know,
at least the linear time attention stuff
has converged a lot into LSTM-like or
linear attention-like architectures and
I don't really see that changing too
much in the in the near future.
Cool. Oh, yes. Well, last question. You
speak about like lower precision
attention, but
I think
is FP4 attention possible?
Um, I think the indexer is partially
motivated by things like this. Like FP4
attention
definitely possible.
Um, I think the drawback is that, you
know, the the loss of precision for
things like soft maxes where like small
underflow, overflow, these kinds of
things can really start to matter can
sometimes be pretty problematic. Um, and
so I think, you know, this motivation of
saying like, okay, like let's do
selection with low precision and then do
a full precision computation afterwards
cuz then the value vectors can be like
more finely added together and weighted
together.
It's a
uh approach that makes sense. I don't
know if there's,
you know, really good ways of um
of doing full attention in in FP4 or
even lower precision of some kind. Yeah.
Okay.
Um, okay, fine. One last question and
then we'll move on.
So,
compared to the transformers
state space models,
what's the downside
Is the training more complicated in the
state space
Yeah, so that's a good question. There
has to be some downside or otherwise
everybody Well, look, like the downside
I think is sort of expressive power,
right? Um, you know, the all-to-all
connection in in soft max attention is
incredibly powerful. It's also very easy
to train, right? Um, it used to be I
think, you know, compared to say an
LSTM, attention had the very strong
advantage of of like hardware
efficiency, right? You could you could
train in parallel. Um, I think the
reason why these state space models have
caught on, you know, despite their
similarity to LSTMs and similar
drawbacks in terms of representational
power is that now, you know, there's
this kind of well-understood duality
because of the linear attention sort of
thing that I talked about where you can
go from, you know, this RNN form to the
more dense matrix multiply form. And the
matrix multiply form allows for
computational efficiency. So, you know,
that trade-off has now been sort of
checked off, but you've still got the
trade-off of if you have a finite state
and you have to carry everything
through,
you know, you you're going to be losing
some information relative to just
carrying everything.
Sorry, what's the context length itself
Well, in state space you have to
basically kind of think about the
context length relative to the size of
your state, right? I mean, if you have a
the state the size of your context, then
you're good to go, but then you're
paying these like very large costs,
right? So, really the the point is the
free lunch is if you want a really tiny
state, it's really hard to compress all
the information in a big context, right?
It might be possible one day to to not
have any trade-offs, but I think thus
far that's where the trade-offs are
showing up.
Cool. Okay, so now I'm going to talk
about mixture of experts.
Um,
and I think mixture of experts are
important to talk about. Um,
conceptually they don't really change
the game. Like one way of thinking about
mixture of experts is they are just a
more efficient MLP, right? Like you take
your MLP and somehow someone gives you
just a more efficient MLP, that is kind
of what mixture of experts is. Um, but I
think you need to understand, you know,
what mixture of experts is. I think for
two reasons. One is kind of this slide
of like everyone's doing MOEs these
days. Everyone's shipping MOEs these
days. Um, you should understand what it
is if you're going to, you know, want to
be
uh
people who deeply understand language
models and how they work, right? So,
that's one reason. Um, the other reason
is that MOEs actually have some really
interesting
um sort of mechanical components to
them. Like if you look at how MOEs are
built and what primitives they use, you
will kind of quickly see MOE-like
primitives in many places. Um, and
you'll kind of realize, wow, I can do
more interesting things with neural
networks. So, there's a broader reason
why I think MOEs are interesting and
cool and you should learn about.
Okay. So, what is an MOE, right? MOEs
are very simple things in some ways.
They're just replacements of your MLP.
So, on the left is your usual MLP for a
transformer, right? You've got your
attention, you've got some
normalization, and then you've got a
feed forward, right? Right after that.
This is kind of where a lot of the
dense, big information processing
happens. Now, um what I can do instead
is let's say I take my big FFN and I'm
going to cut them up into smaller FFNs,
right? So, I have now have four feed
forward networks. Um, and let's say
actually let's say I don't cut them up
into smaller pieces. Let's say they're
the same size
as my original FFN. And somehow, right?
By some magic, I have a system that
tells me which FFN to pick for every
input, right? Now, what I've done is I
have 4x the parameters or at least for
my FFN, right? I have four FFNs worth of
parameters, but on any forward or
backward pass, right? I'm only going to
pay one FFN worth of cost, right? That's
great. So, in some sense, you know, the
original motivations for MOEs, if you
read the original papers, have this like
very um parameter-centric view. You
know, if you it start something like,
"Well, let's say you just wanted more
parameters because you believe more
parameters are good." It's like, okay,
good. If we want more parameters and we
don't want to pay the cost for more
parameters, you need something like
something on the right, right? So, this
is this is the mental model that you
should have for MOEs, right? You want to
increase parameters without affecting
your flops.
Now, why are they so popular, right?
Every model that you get on hugging face
or whatever these days are MOEs past a
certain size, right? Past a certain
size, everything that you get seems to
be an MOE. Um, and the reason is because
it seems to be the case that for
whatever reason, if you keep the total
compute the same, but you just increase
the number of sparse parameters, right?
Somehow the models are generally getting
better, right? So, this is uh
evidence maybe in favor of the view that
more parameters are in fact generally
good even if only a subset of them are
active at a time. Um, and I'm going to,
you know, refer to some of the original
Google papers extensively throughout
this lecture. This one's from uh Fedus
et al. in 2022 um where they were doing
I think the switch transformer for this
one. You know, and they're showing, oh,
as you increase the number of experts,
right? So, this is active parameter
stays the same, number of experts
increases, you know, your test loss for
language modeling is just decreasing,
decreasing, decreasing. That's lovely if
all you care about is your forward pass
flops.
Um, on the right you see sort of similar
things um as you, you know, you train
faster, right? As you increase uh your
training compute on the x-axis, if you
have more experts for the same amount of
training compute, you just get better
performance, right? So, for both
training and inference, um MOEs just
give you a free win, right? This is
pretty pretty wonderful. It's pretty
great.
Um
And this is really, you know, something
that's been
seen many times. This is the same plot
from before on the left from the Fedus
paper um last year, I think. Um,
AIQ folks put out this Olmo paper which
was their like open source mixture of
experts uh analysis and sort of training
paper and they see the same thing as
well. If you look at um training loss or
validation loss or sort of uh downstream
benchmark performance, you see that um
in training time, right? Um, these
models are doing much better as MOEs um
compared to their dense counterparts.
So, something like uh two times faster
or something like that um training an
MOE relative to a dense model. So, you
can really see the benefits of sparsity
here.
Um
And, you know, I think the proof is in
the pudding, but if you look at all the
MOEs that got released, you know, they
are much stronger than dense models in
terms of activated parameters, which is
what matters if you care about inference
flops, or really even, you know, just in
general the cost to train and serve
these systems, right? Like the the
all-in cost. So, when DeepSeek V2 and
like the earlier DeepSeek MOEs came out,
you know, it was really kind of a big
shift from a lot of these dense models
that everyone else was training. You
kind of saw that, wow, we have much
fewer active parameters, you know, just
as good if not better MMLU performance
uh compared to everyone else, right? So,
this is this is a really good stuff
happening with MOEs.
Okay. So, hopefully I've convinced you
that MOEs are like an interesting thing
that you should like spend your time
thinking about
and studying. Oh, right. And then one
last thing that I'll say for for why
this is important is MOEs give you
another axis of parallelization.
We'll talk about parallelization in
systems in
three three more lectures, I think.
But parallelization is actually one of
the really big important things in LLMs.
LLMs are very big. They don't fit in
single devices either to train or
inference. So, you want many different
ways of cutting up your model to
efficiently serve or train them.
Mixture of experts have this additional
nice thing that you can do where your
experts within each FFN naturally come
in different, you know, chunks, right?
Each expert is a natural chunk. You can
put them on different devices, and then
you can route the activations to
different devices. We'll talk about
expert parallel later, which is what
this is, but this gives you an
additional systems thing that you can
optimize, which is very helpful if you
want to sort of optimize your serving.
Okay.
Um in the west, you know, I think
there's been several open-source
releases that are big strong MOEs.
On the big model side, there was Llama 4
and
GPT-OSS from OpenAI. Unfortunately, I
guess open-source model releases in the
west have kind of stalled for the most
part. So, there aren't quite as many
being released now, but you know,
there's at least two good examples of
this.
You know, both top-tier models in their
own right.
Um
But I think a lot of the action for both
MOE research and training has happened
in China.
Qwen and DeepSeek
and some others like MiniCPM did some of
the earliest work kind of training and
popularizing MOEs. They continue to do
really great work on MOEs.
You know, if you look at some of the
early Qwen MOE models, this was Qwen 1.5
MOE.
You know, they showed that they're like
small 2.7 billion parameter active model
you know, was doing better than many of
the 7B models at the time. And I think
some of this early proof of work from
DeepSeek and Qwen really convinced
everyone else in the open-source
community that this was the right way to
go. Um
And speaking of DeepSeek, oh, was there
a question? Yes.
I guess one one question I had about
like the expert parallel. Like isn't
there like a communication bottleneck
that's built up because these experts
are communicating with each other?
Yes. So, in some sense, you pay the
communication cost of like shipping an
activation over. And you know, I will
not explain, but I will show you one
trick of like how you reduce that.
But in general, you're like trading
certain things off. You're getting more
aggregate flops. You're reducing your
memory use. In exchange, you're going to
pay for coms, right? So, you know, it's
highly dependent on your topology and
all these other things whether this is
going to be a net win.
Cool. Oh, yeah. I was going to say
during training though,
though they
During Okay, this is this is the
important part. During training, they
are also sparse, right? This is really
the key thing that makes MOEs hard. I
mean, I'm I'm, you know, spoilering sort
of the key idea from a few slides down,
but it would be very easy if we
activated all the experts during
training, right? Because then we get to
see, oh, which expert is good for my
input. So, you you get to learn how to
route. The hard thing about MOEs is that
during training, you only have, you
know, one or K experts active. So, you
don't know what happened with the rest
of them.
Right? You only know the ones that
activated. Despite this, you must
somehow learn to route. Right? So, it's
kind of got this RL bandit flavor to the
problem.
But we're not going to solve it with
either RL or bandit. So, we're going to
solve it with the power of heuristics
and deep learning magic, right? Okay,
yes.
What is the granularity of switching
between experts? Uh so, the granularity
as in like the scale at which we route
experts is at token level. If I don't
know if Okay, good. Good. That was the
question. Yes, at the token level. So,
every token gets an expert. And the
routers, you know, just to get your your
sort of like mental model correct, the
routers are super naive, right? They're
like a single matrix multiply between
your input and your whatever. And so,
you're not going to do anything
complicated. You don't know it's like a
medical question or not. You're like,
oh, this is a token that looks like it's
in, you know, I don't know, Japanese.
Let's route it to expert seven, right?
Yes. Uh yeah, so is there any upper
limit to parallelizing
[clears throat and snorts]
uh
these uh MOE models
in in training or inference? Yeah, in
general, there's upper limit to
parallelization because, you know, as
you shard over more and more devices,
the communication cost explodes, right?
You will Well, if we if we get the
assignment to design done correctly, you
will have to deal with some of these in
your assignment. We will we will ask you
to figure out the networking topology
and things like this that will
make sharding make sense. Or it's the
reverse. Given a networking topology,
you'll have to figure out how to shard
models and things like this. Yeah.
Good. Okay.
Um right.
DeepSeek, you know, now known for like
DeepSeek R1 and so on. But I think the
thing I really like about DeepSeek, and
originally this lecture was a, you know,
let's just go through a DeepSeek paper
lecture that very first iteration.
Um is that they've done actually really
good architecture and LLM science work
for a long time. And DeepSeek were one
of the earlier ones, you know, going
through and showing why MOEs are good.
And they have a lot of ton of good
ablation work on like, oh, what happens
if we use a dense layer? What if we use
hash routing? What if we use a switch
router? You know, all these different
kinds of design decisions you can see in
some of their earlier DeepSeek MOE
papers. So, if you're interested in a
lot of these questions like architecture
design and so on, I would suggest you
read their earlier DeepSeek papers.
There's a lot to learn from all of
these, right?
And of course, progress hasn't stopped.
You know, DeepSeek V3 and V3.2 and like
GLM and so on have built these like
wonderful very strong MOE models.
It's quite clear that this is kind of
where the future of these big models are
going to be for the foreseeable future.
At least the next couple years, I
imagine will be MOEs.
Okay. So, now the question is, why
haven't they they be
Why haven't they been more popular? In
many different ways, I feel like MOEs
caught on pretty slowly. You know, you
look at some of these papers like in
2022, right? Google was studying and
really trying to like push MOEs. Um
but, you know, it's only in like 2024
onwards that MOEs really started to
catch on. Like why? Also, you know, if
you're doing LLM research of various
kinds, you're probably mostly working
with dense models. Like why not MOE
models if they're so nice, right? We can
save on compute.
Um there's a lot of complexities that
come from MOEs. Like it's not easy to
train a MOE or to use a MOE to or to do
many things.
Um you know, the infrastructure is very
complex. I mean, there were a couple
questions about parallelization, but
this is like generally right. That it's
hard to parallelize, you know, experts
in ways that are like efficient in
utilization. MOEs have a lot of
parameters. It's hard to fit them on a
single device.
And if you're training them, the MOEs
can really blow up on you. And you'll
see why in a few slides why MOEs are
just really hard to deal with. But
they're just not easy objects to work
with, right? I mean, there's good rules
of thumb now, but it's not easy.
Okay.
Um I'll briefly mention with one slide
that there are people that also, you
know, kind of mixture of experts the
attention block in transformers. There
have been a couple papers,
but they are much less common. And I
think the, you know, things that I have
seen is that they haven't been quite as
easy to tame or to to get to work
compared to just replacing the the FFN
or the MLP layer, right? So, I'm only
going to talk about the left. This is
basically uh what all the big models do.
Um people are not, for the most part,
sharding or sorry, splitting up
attention heads into experts.
Okay. So, that was kind of the broad
industrial overview of like MOEs and
like what the state of things are. Um
but now let's like talk about how you
design an MOE, how you think about an
MOE. So,
um to do that, I'm going to talk about
three different kind of
axes of variation, right? Um so, what
kinds of things can change for MOEs?
Well, you can change the routing
function, right? We know that MOEs have
this core thing of like a router has to
send tokens to experts, right? So, we
can change that. We can change the sizes
of the different experts, right? For a
given budget, you might have more
experts with fewer parameters or fewer
experts with more parameters. Um and
then finally, we're going to talk about
training, right? Because training is
going to be really difficult. Like once
you start to realize how MOEs work, you
realize, wow, it is not easy to train
something that routes tokens to
different places.
Okay. So, in all cases, we don't want to
activate all the experts, right? Like we
want to only have some subset of experts
active. Um and so, we are going to
always be choosing some top K. There is
different kinds of choices that you can
do.
You can have the token choose the
expert. You can have the expert choose
the token. So, each expert picks, you
know, their favorite tokens. Or you can
have each token uh pick their favorite
experts. Or you can somehow have this
like very complicated router that like
globally decides, oh yes, you token
should go to this expert and this other
token should go to that other experts to
try to like globally optimize
assignments.
Um
So,
basically almost all the MOEs do token
choice top K. And so, the token is going
to be the one to choose the experts. And
there's going to be K different experts
that get sort of selected to be in the
pool.
And you can sort of see, you know, this
is from the OLMo paper,
differences between token choice and
expert choice.
You see that token choice is going to
get, you know, lower validation losses,
higher downstream benchmark scores
compared to expert choice. Um There have
been successful expert choice models. I
mean, this also trains fine, you know.
But token choice has generally been much
easier to get working. It has been kind
of the standard for all of the models
that kind of we see today.
I think one of the llama four models was
maybe expert choice, but I don't think
that's necessarily a a strong vote of
confidence.
Uh
What?
I don't think I think that was one of
the unreleased llama four models, you
know, in my in my defense.
Um okay, so I think there's many
different ways that you can do routing.
So one of the ways that you can do
routing is you can actually have a small
small sort of
ML like a linear projection that says,
"Okay, I'm going to get my input. My
router is an inner inner product. Um
each expert has sort of a vector
direction and the sort of the closest in
inner product space will get selected."
This is by far the most common router.
It's used in the classic switch
transformer, the GShard, those two are
the early Google papers. It's used in
Grok, Mistral, Plan, DBRX, Deep Seek,
and others, right? Um the number of K
that you choose varies depending on, you
know, which paper you're looking at.
Um but for the most part, you know,
you're you're just taking inner
products.
Um one thing that has always been a
little mysterious to me um is that many
many papers have shown that actually you
don't need to do any sort of like
learned routing. You can just take your
X's, you can hash them, and send them to
different uh feedforward networks. And
actually this is fine, too. This
sometimes or this gives gains. Not as
much as top K, but somehow hashing-based
uh expert routing is also, you know,
something that people do. Common
baseline in papers.
Um not used in in deployment for for
real reasons for many reasons.
Um you can do RL to learn the routes.
You can basically have a router that's a
inner product router.
Um and you can sort of use reinforcement
learning to try to treat this router as
a kind of policy and then learn it. Um
You know, if you're a machine learning
like classic, you know, learning theory
type oriented person, I think this
should be the natural way to think about
the problem, right? You're like, "Okay,
what am I doing? It's kind of like a
bandit problem. I'm selecting one out of
K or K out of N.
Um and I don't observe all of them. This
is a bandit problem. I will use a bandit
or an RL algorithm, right?" Um used in
some of the earliest work because this
is kind of the natural way to think
about the problem like Bengio in 2013.
Um but it is not a common approach. Um
And I think the reason why it's not
common is because, you know, the
approaches needed to you do RL introduce
a lot of overhead in terms of both the
RL algorithm and the stochasticity.
Um
and what people have figured out is
there's a good set of heuristics like
these recipes that you can apply to this
very simple classic top K routing scheme
um that basically just has it working,
right? And so there's no reason to do
something much more complicated. Um I
will finally sort of mention, you know,
an idea that I think is really cool and
that I love as a person that likes
things that make sense. Um you can solve
a linear assignment problem where you
say, "Okay, I'm going to globally
compute kind of the score that says
like, oh, it would be um
this good for this token to go to that
expert." Right? So you compute this all
pairwise scores of how good the
assignments are. And you can use linear
assignment to exactly solve for the for
the optimal assignment from experts to
tokens. Um it's been used. It's been
shown to to do good things in some
cases.
Um hasn't been seen at scale at all, I
would think because it's, you know,
extremely expensive relative to the
others
uh to get working.
Okay.
Um so top K routing, as I said, is
basically the consensus routing
mechanism. Um how does this work? It's
very very simple. And if you, you know,
were were paying attention in the DSA uh
slide, this looks a lot like DSA, right?
Um you'll also notice this if you were
reading some other papers like H-Nets or
these other kinds of things. This will
appear in many different places. So this
is a good kind of pattern to be able to
to sort of recognize. Um so what you're
doing is you are going to
um
take in your inputs. Um and you're going
to take it through sort of a
feedforward. And then I'm going to
compute um some sort of scores. And the
scores that I'm going to compute is
going to be um
the softmax between the experts and sort
of my my inputs U. And then this S is
going to be the scores. And I'm going to
select the top K of those guys, and
that's going to be the gate that's going
to control each of my experts, right? So
so this is like input, this is the
residual term, this is the FFN. I've got
gates, and the gates are controlled top
K, right? This is kind of the equation
form of what you would imagine of a top
K router. And the only, you know, detail
that you're probably learning here is
how do I learn my gates? My gates are
just learned by taking inner product
between a weight for each expert and the
inputs that I have, right? Very very
lightweight, right? So there's nothing
complicated about the ways that I'm
going to select my gates.
Um
even within this simple thing, there's
been some innovation and variation from
uh DeepSeek
um and friends. Um DeepSeek MoE uh
pioneered this idea, which is now very
widely used, called shared experts.
Um
this is a very intuitive idea
um where, you know, in the classic top K
router you would have, you know, K
different Oh, sorry. In this case, N
different experts. Um and these experts,
you know, you would select amongst them.
But sometimes you might say, "Well,
there's some processing some very common
processing that I want to apply to all
tokens, right?" Like maybe you don't
want experts to be different every time.
You want some experts to always be
applied. And then some other experts to
be applied conditionally, right? So um
what DeepSeek MoE did was they took sort
of the uh original expert design. They
cut up the experts into smaller
finer-grained chunks. And some subset of
those fine-grained experts were were
sort of set as shared experts that are
always on, right? So these sort of
bypass the router. They always process
our inputs and they sort of go back on
the outputs. Oh, sorry.
Um
and this is a nice idea because it
turned out that, you know, if you have
this classic expert design, you were
just kind of reusing a lot of these
weights to do common modeling. And so
you can offload this into the one shared
expert, letting these guys specialize
even more. Um and you know, as I was
kind of saying, DeepSeek is really nice
in that they do careful ablations in a
lot of their papers. Um and so, you
know, they have this very nice ablation
where they look at, you know, zero
shared experts, and then you have these
big experts, 16 routed experts. And this
is really the old GShard Google design.
Um compared to, you know, they have very
fine-grained segmentation of experts and
one shared expert amongst these. And you
know, as you make the experts smaller
and smaller um and you have one shared
expert, you see significant gains from
both of those interventions. And and for
some of these, you know, the shared
expert has very significant improvements
like TriviaQA, Natural Questions. This
blue to yellow gap, right, is shared
experts or not.
So more experts, shared experts all
generally seem to help. And if you want
sort of more validation of
uh these claims and ideas, uh you see
this from Elmo as well. Elmo was I think
the nice uh western sort of carefully
controlled uh MoE study. They do things
like, "Oh, do shared experts help?" Um
they conclude that shared experts don't
help very much. Um and you know, number
of experts they show, you know, doing
fine-grained many experts is helpful. So
they disagree a little bit on the shared
expert point. Um
but, you know, they also have very nice
carefully controlled ablations.
Um many of the recent MoEs uh do follow
essentially the DeepSeek design. Um
you know, there were a couple of early
MoEs uh up until this point. Um
the the first three, you know, I I keep
giving Google praise for doing lots of
interesting things. You know, the first
three were from Google. Um Mistral,
DBRX, and Grok were some of the early
MoE attempts in the west. DeepSeek V1
comes up with sort of both the
fine-grained and shared expert design.
And then that sort of catches on and
everyone else sort of, you know, follows
from DeepSeek. I mean, it's a similar, I
would say, phenomenon to to the llama
design for dense transformers being, you
know, essentially the standard. DeepSeek
MoE and DeepSeek V3 are kind of the
standard design that people have copied
for the MoE side of things.
And if you look at like Qwen 3.5 or GLM
or any of these modern models, you
continue to see uh both shared experts
and fine-grained experts uh in
widespread use amongst all these people.
And so that's been a very battle-tested
um design.
Okay.
Um any questions? Oh, yes, good. Yeah,
if there is a
if there is a shared expert uh or there
are like few shared experts, right?
Uh how would
parallelization work in that case?
Um Yeah. So in the shared expert case,
you know, you wouldn't get any
parallelization savings. Like every
every activation has to route through
those. Like you can copy the shared
expert um
to basically eat memory savings to
reduce comms cost.
Cool.
All right. So that's kind of the sort of
design space of routers. Now I want to
talk about training MoEs. And this is
like, you know, it gets into really
surprising and I would say very deep
learning things about this. Um I think
initially when I was learning about
MoEs, I thought there's no way that we
can train these things well or like
reasonably. But it turns out there are
lots of, you know, tricks that when when
combined together like just really work
well um and robustly for for some
reason.
Um
so as was sort of raised in the previous
question, right? We don't want to
activate all the experts during
training, right? Because if we do that,
we're going to pay the full flops cost
of all of our experts. And we have a lot
of experts. So we need sparsity for
efficiency of training time.
But if we have sparsity, then gating
decisions are no longer differentiable.
And we also don't see all the different
counterfactual experts we could have
picked, right? So these are both big
problems.
Um so there are different solutions. We
could use RL to optimize our gating
policies. I already mentioned this, not
super popular.
Um you could do things like stochastic
perturbations, right? So if you're
familiar with like, you know,
explore-exploit bandit style stuff, you
could do some of that.
Now, the third one is you could kind of
have a whole bunch of weird heuristics
that, you know, deal with the fact that
the gating decisions are sparse to
balance out which experts go where.
Um you know, guess which one people use
in practice. I've been kind of hinting
at this. Um it's number three, right?
It's a it's a collection of really
interesting heuristics that end up
working.
Um I'll talk about uh the other two
first. Um they're not widely used. I
would I would, you know, open with that.
Um but I think it's useful to know. Um
so, some people have done, you know,
this is from Clark 2020, um research on
things like can you use RL to learn
routers? Um so, it does work. You can
use RL. This is the the green line over
here. Um that's one of the baseline
approaches. It works fine, but because
of the gradient variance and complexity,
it's not, you know, actually the optimal
thing to do. And even sort of some of
the approaches that are proposed in this
paper, you know, handily beat using
reinforce gradients for routing
decisions.
Now, something that's very close to the
idea of RL,
um but sort of starts to move more
towards this like heuristic world of
like, you know, uh
write down objectives and try things, um
is this idea of a stochastic
approximation. And it comes from um the
earliest
uh sort of MOE paper from Noam Shazeer
and others. Um where what you do is you
don't really make a hard decision during
training. What you do is you make
stochastic decisions. So, what you do
is, you know, you still have this sort
of routing uh setup. So, this H is sort
of the um you have the inner product
between your parameters and your inputs.
This is your, you know, standard routing
inner product. But then, instead of just
doing this, I'm going to uh inject some
noise that's kind of, you know,
dependent on the scale of the input. And
then that's going to be my H. And now,
I'm going to keep the top K and softmax
just like I was explaining with top K.
Um and then that's going to be, you
know, the the output that goes in to the
to my uh top K uh function.
Now, if you look at this, you know, what
is this doing? Well, it just means that
if you have two experts that are like
closely tied or it's like very close to
each other, then stochastically you'll
pick one of them and not the other,
right? And as you backprop, you're going
to backprop in a way that like, you
know, the the experts that are helpful
will get high weights. So, this, you
know, perturbation allows you to like
tiebreak and explore a little bit more,
and hopefully the gradient structure is
such that if an expert is helpful, um
it's going to sort of emphasize that
expert more and it will get higher and
higher weights in general, right? So,
this is one reasonable thing that you
can do. It leads to experts that are a
bit more robust, um and you the softmax,
you know, allows you to to learn how to
rank all these K experts, right? Rather
than just doing a hard selection of top
K, you're kind of waiting by these
elements.
Okay.
Um there's another sort of scheme that's
very closely related that's done in Fit
Fedus et al. in 2022, which does kind of
a uniform multiplicative perturbation.
Um they do this for the reason of like
hardening the experts, like making them
robust. Um
this was a useful thing to do, but this
was later removed in in later Google
papers that do sort of routing. And it's
not really clear that this is, you know,
necessary at all. Um you kind of see
later ablation showing that, you know,
not doing any any of these like
stochastic sort of robustness tricks, um
actually helps um with uh both stability
and overall quality of the final trained
MOE. Um
So, this kind of suggests, you know, you
don't need necessarily these stochastic
exploration terms.
So,
this takes us to what you actually do,
um which is a series of sort of
heuristics that, you know, in the end is
going to give us a working uh MOE.
And a lot of these have to do with
essentially balancing. So, what's the
problem if you just do normal gradient
descent ignoring any of these like
exploration exploitation concerns? Well,
what's going to happen is you're going
to first route your top K experts, and
then sort of the strongest of those
experts will get sort of more signal.
Your your backprop is going to say that
expert was good, you know, increase the
weight of that expert, right? Move that
parameter closer to that. So, you get
this rich gets richer effect where sort
of experts that are chosen get very
strong weights. Strong weights means
that they're selected more often, and
you they kind of run away taking on all
everything. And so,
this expert collapse phenomenon, or like
expert, you know, uh starvation
phenomenon, is a very very real problem.
Um and in some sense, this is the core
issue that you have to solve with sort
of heuristic training uh of MOEs. And
so, what do you do? Well, what you do is
you add a sort of heuristic loss um to
the total modeling loss. And this loss
is supposed to balance out the tokens
that go to different experts. Um and
sort of one approach, which is done in
the Switch Transformer over here, um
you can kind of look at what this does.
So, this is um
you have different experts going from uh
one to N, and you have a a batch of
tokens. And what you want to do is you
want to make sure that these two inner
products are kind of small. Okay, so
what is happening here? F is the
fraction of tokens that are dispatched
to any single tok uh any single expert.
And then P of I is kind of the softer
version. This is not just the whether
the token is dispatched to an expert,
this is the total probability mass of
the router that's allocated. Um and you
multiply these two two terms. Um and
this is like
at least to me, not a thing where you
would like derive it from first
principles. I think the easiest way to
kind of see what this thing is doing is
to take the derivative of this object.
So, if you take the derivative of this
with respect to P of I, and P of I
remember is the uh probability mass
allocated to an expert, well, the
derivative is going to be the fraction
of uh tokens that are allocated. So, in
some sense, you can think of this as a
penalty in the gradient space, where the
more tokens you get, the sort of more
negative gradient you get, right? So, so
this is trying to push down the the
probability mass on very popular experts
proportional to their fraction. Um and
that's kind of the action of this loss,
right? That's the way to think about it.
So, um
you know, the the objective itself in
equation four might not be clear to
start with, but once you sort of reason
about the action of the uh the gradient,
it becomes kind of clear what this is
trying to do, which is to push down
popular uh experts.
So, you know, then we can actually take
these ideas and essentially reconstruct
um Deep Seek V1 and twos uh MOE system.
So, what do you do to build Deep Seek
MOE? Well, you're going to do your
normal losses, and you're just going to
backprop straight through the experts,
ignoring all this non-differentiability
and like exploration concerns. But
you're going to add per expert balancing
that's identical to the Switch
Transformer, what I just showed you,
right? So, you're going to have this
loss that multiplies F, which is the
fraction, and P, which is the total
mass. Um
but, you know, Deep Seek folks, they're
very savvy with their sort of systems
design, so they don't just balance the
experts, right? They also want to
balance by device. So, if your experts
are allocated to some devices, so let's
say, you know, my machine over here has
four experts, this machine over here has
another four experts, um you want those
two machines to be balanced. So, both of
them are kind of running at full
utilization, right? So, you don't want
to just make the experts even, you also
want to ensure that the devices are
even, right? So, this is a secondary
objective. It acts in exactly the same
way. If you look at the function here,
instead of experts, you're just
operating on each device's fraction. You
apply the secondary device balancing
loss just for utilization reasons.
Um
in Deep Seek V3, um they have sort of a
per expert bias term that they use, um
and they use kind of a online learning
trick to uh sort of balance out experts,
sort of getting rid of some of these uh
auxiliary losses. Um
but sort of, you know, they they do in
in the end have to add some of these
auxiliary losses in order to ensure like
extreme imbalances don't happen. So, I
think, you know, I I add this as kind of
a side note that, you know, Deep Seek V3
and others have started to get rid of
some of these like, I would say, uglier
auxiliary losses, but there's no kind of
solution that fully gets rid of them
uh so far.
Okay.
Um the last thing I'll talk about with
load balancing losses is, you know, you
might ask like, do I need to deal with
this, right? It's all a bunch of
complicated heuristics. Um I wish I
could just get rid of the load balancing
loss, um but if you remove the load
balancing loss, you know, kind of the
effects are pretty catastrophic. Um
these are both from the Olmo paper where
they do this nice ablation of removing
the load balancing loss entirely. Um if
you have the load balancing loss, you
get this pink line at the top, very nice
normal curves. Remove the load balancing
loss, you know, your losses, you know,
significantly increase, um and your
training loss also is is not doing so
well. Maybe more tellingly, if you look
at, you know, which experts are doing
what, um
with load balancing and without load
load balancing, that's these bottom
panels over here,
you see a really really stark
difference. Without load balancing,
almost all the tokens are going to two
experts, right? The yellow expert uh and
the pinkish expert that you see here. Um
whereas if you have the load balancing
loss, even though we had this kind of
heuristic thing going on, all of these
experts are being utilized across the
tokens. So, we have the nice even
utilization, right?
Um so, we do kind of see that the load
balancing loss does what we'd expect.
And without it, you know, we've thrown
away a ton of parameters. Those experts
are doing absolutely nothing uh for most
of training.
Right? So, this is kind of how uh MOEs
are trained. Um and I think, you know,
just to to go back, this is pretty
surprising to me that you've got this
thing that's like kind of
non-differentiable, you're doing this
top K selection, and it's
honestly a pretty complicated object. Um
and all you really need to do is to just
add this balancing loss to even out the
experts, and then the rest of it you
treat it as if you can just pump
gradients through the system,
um and the model trains very nicely. Um
and I think a big part of this is, you
know, this dynamic that if an expert is
useful, you're going to reinforce it,
and that's a sort of positive re- uh
positive reinforcement cycle that's
nicely sort of balanced out by evening
things out, right? Those two dynamics
cancel each other out.
Um
Cool. Oh, and the and the final thing
I'll say is, you know, that same trick
is used in uh DSA, right? We already saw
the top K thing. It's used um in things
like H-Net if you're familiar with that.
That was a attempt to remove tokenizers.
Um and so I think you'll you'll see this
trick um
more often in the future, where this
idea of like top K selection and using
um load balancing or other kinds of
auxiliary losses to enable that
non-differentiability will be sort of a
ingredient of future architecture
design.
Yes.
Is there any way of relating mixture of
experts to like systems optimization,
but like
are they actually experts when you look
at them? Are they actually doing things
in different domains? Yeah, so some
papers have um a visualization of which
tokens are activated by which experts.
And because the routers are so simple,
it's not like, you know, experts are
like smart experts. They're not like
medical experts, legal experts, or
whatever. You do see that certain tokens
are routed to different things. Like,
you know, punctuations might be routed
to one expert, uh or like other symbols
might be routed to one expert. You know,
non-English language character sets
might be routed to another expert. Um
but it's not really something where you
can like look at it and be like, "Oh,
this is the Wall Street Journal expert."
or something, right? Um nothing like
that.
There's no semantics is maybe one way of
putting it. Yeah. Yeah. Why is there a
per expert loss
versus a per device loss?
That's what's interesting to this. Yeah,
the per expert loss, in principle, if
it's perfectly enforced, will also
enforce a per device balancing if your
experts are evenly split, right? Um but
I think at least my interpretation of
that is, you know, you don't want to
crank up the per expert loss so high
that you get true full uniformity, cuz
that has deleterious effects on training
dynamics. But per device is important
enough that you're willing to add on a
little bit of extra loss to encourage
per device balancing over others.
Cool. Okay. So now I'm going to talk a
little bit about the system side of
things um before we wrap up.
So
um training MOEs has additional fun
systems dynamics that are introduced. Um
when I talk about parallelism, I'm
mostly going to talk about, you know,
the the standard, let's call it, forms
of parallelism. You can you know, split
up your data into many small chunks. Um
or sorry, you can split up your data
over many small chunks. You can take
your one data set and split it up over
many sort of machines. Um you can do
model parallelism, where, you know, you
can take your model, and maybe you can,
you know, split up your model over uh
different machines. Um and you can
combine those two in various ways. You
can of course do that. Um but I think
the the thing that we realized is each
of those parallelism techniques has some
sort of limit, right? For data
parallelism, you know, you're maxed out
your batch size, right? Once you you hit
your batch size, you can't parallelize
by data anymore. For model size, there's
natural sort of like cut points where
you can cut your model. Once you exhaust
those, you can't parallelize anymore. Um
if you combine this with expert
parallelism, you got another additional
nice axis to parallelize on. Um and when
you do this,
um a lot of the the underlying
implementations for this allow you to
take advantage of uh sparse matrix
multiply that has been built in to GPUs.
Um so the another thing that I'll
mention is like if you're if you have
multiple experts, right? Let's say on
one GPU, um one way of thinking about it
is to say, "I'm going to have multiple
small matrix multiplies." But this is
not nice because you ideally want these
like bigger matrix multiplies where you
can reuse caches and do all sorts of
things. So instead, what you can do is
you can, you know, nicely leverage
sparsity, and block diagonal, of course,
is the most basic form, but you can use
much more sort of complicated forms of
structured sparsity that are sort of
natively supported in hardware um to
allow you to essentially multiply uh
sort of experts and inputs in very, very
clean ways uh very fast, right? So this
is another reason why MOEs are nice. If
you think about the the sort of
computation patterns of MOEs, they
almost correspond to these kinds of
structured matrix multiplications that
are very easy and efficient to support
in hardware, right? So there's this
hardware architecture co-design that's
kind of happening um with MOEs.
Um and in terms of parallelism, um one
thing I'll mention, this is a very
recent development. This is from uh
Neumitron 3. Um you know, as I I forgot
who asked this question, um
uh
you know, when we do this expert
parallelism, we have to be shipping
activations from device to device in
order to say like, "Oh, you belong in
that expert. I need to ship you over."
That can result in significant
communications overhead.
So some of the things that people have
started to think about is to say, "Well,
my shared expert, which, you know, I'm
not going to communicate, this can be,
you know, in big dimensions, but my
experts, I need to communicate those
activations. I want those to be in
smaller, lower dimensional vectors,
right?" So you might actually take your
your sort of residual stream and down
project it first, and then decide to do
sort of the collective communication
call of sending this activation out. And
that will significantly save on uh
communication without sort of fully
having the the drawbacks of having a
smaller hidden dimension size, right? So
So you can actually do these like kind
of projection tricks to to nicely
control uh the trade-off of uh
communication and uh having your MOEs
parallelized.
Okay. One final sort of uh trivia, let's
call it, detail uh of MOEs that I think
is fun, um but it has been solved in
recent years, is stochasticity. If you
do MOE sort of infrastructure naively,
what you'll find is that unless your
experts are sort of perfectly balanced
on your input sort of distribution,
you'll find that certain experts might
be much more popular than others.
And if, you know, some expert, like
let's say in this case expert zero, is
just a really popular expert, you're
going to actually start running into
situations where this expert sort of
queue of tokens just starts building up
and building up and building up, and
eventually you'll get to a point where
you say, "My queue is so long, I have to
start dropping tokens." right?
Um in the earlier generation of uh MOE
inference sort of infrastructure and
code, a lot of what happened was you
would just actually silently drop this
expert, and you just proceed on with
your computation as if nothing has
happened. You know, you just send a zero
back and pretend that that was fine. Um
and this means that, it, you know, you
you can have like these weird
stochasticities where if other users,
you know, sending queries that hit the
experts that you're using, then you
could actually get a worse result
because they would kind of bump you out
of the expert queue. You know, these
kinds of very strange things can happen.
Um but these days there's sort of
dropless architectures that have gotten
rid of a lot of these issues. So this is
no longer really a a issue. So
MegaBlocks and other sort of very common
open-source MOE
uh frameworks don't have this issue
anymore.
Okay. So the last thing that I'll talk
about in terms of the design of MOEs is
this issue of stability. Um we've
already talked about stability issues in
the context of um architecture design
last lecture.
But, you know, if you remember what I
said then, I said, you know,
exponentials are bad, divisions are bad,
which means soft maxes are, you know,
danger zone for stability issues. Now,
what have we done with um mixture of
experts? Well, we have introduced yet
another soft max in the routing, right?
Because we're going to do top K, we're
going to do soft max, and that's going
to be sort of how we route uh to
experts.
Now, um you know, people have long
noticed that the soft max operation in
MOEs are potentially very, very
dangerous. Um Barrett Zoph and others in
early days of sort of Google MOE design
sort of had an entire paper on MOE
stability, and this was one of the
things that they noticed. Um and you
know, I'm going to go into some of the
details. You know, you'll see the
solution fairly often for some of the
more sensitive and tricky parts. You
know, you might end up using something
like float32 for just the expert router.
Um you might have a Z loss as well here.
Um we've talked about Z loss before um
in order to control the soft max
stability issues that we saw.
Um Z loss, I think, was was quite
popular, actually,
uh to do MOE router work uh
MOE router stability even in the early
days. Um OLMo, which I've been talking
about extensively, has done ablations
on, you know, adding or removing Z loss.
You know, it's quite clear from these
very spiky training loss curves that Z
loss on the router um can be quite
helpful.
There are other issues with MOEs that
you can uh end up with. Um and I think,
you know, you probably all have
experienced this maybe recently if you
work with language models, um which is
that MOEs can be pretty annoying to
fine-tune. They have so many parameters
that if you're trying to fine-tune the
the um experts, you actually end up with
very sort of serious overfitting issues.
So you can kind of see
um that if you have your dense models,
train and val are, you know, fairly
close. They don't overfit crazily. But
if you look at the sparse, train and val
gap is, you know, extremely large as you
fine-tune these models for in this case
uh downstream task. Uh it was I think it
was one of the GLUE benchmark tasks.
Now,
um
you know, you could have a case where,
you know, you fine-tune um non-MOE
feedforwards. You could also fine-tune
just attention. These are pretty common
interventions that people uh do.
Especially the attention fine-tuning is
something that I see quite often with uh
MOE works recently. But if your model
has non-MOE layers, then of course you
can also just fine-tune those. And
Barrett Zoph and others, you know, were
were kind of arguing for those. Um and
of course there's also the uh kind of
bitter lesson version of this, which is
um you know, maybe you should just use
1.4 million examples instead of, you
know, whatever number you have. If you
have a lot of data, you know, you can
retrain basically the MOE entirely
during your fine-tuning stage, and you
won't have quite as much of a
generalization gap.
Okay. Um, the last MOE specific trick uh
that I'll mention is uh this idea of uh
upcycling. This has actually become a
lot less popular in the last year. I
don't think I've seen a single upcycled
model this year. Um, but it's a cool
idea. And also, there were some very
nice models earlier on using this trick.
So, I I kind of want to mention this.
Um, so upcycling is this idea that, you
know, if you want that MOE, maybe you
can just take a dense model that you've
trained, and then you can instantiate a
MOE based on that dense model. And the
idea is you just copy everything,
including the MLPs. You just make a
whole bunch of copies from of these
MLPs. You have a router, which, you
know, have a random initialization. Um,
and then you just train this model. And
if you do this, then, you know, because
of the stochasticity of which inputs go
to where in the MLP, um you're going to
get these experts that start to
specialize. Um, and in the end, you'll
actually end up with a MOE.
Um, and in sort of some of the earliest
papers that proposed upcycling,
you know, they showed that an upcycled
method um could get, you know, much
better sort of uh language modeling sort
of val- in this case, accuracy uh
performance um sort of upcycling a dense
model rather than continuing to train
the same model. Um, which is kind of a
cool uh thing that you can show.
People have sort of validated this kind
of uh at scale in many ways. So, MiniCPM
is another sort of, you know, Chinese
model that, you know, I quite like
because they do a lot of carefully
controlled ablations. They had a MOE
where they took their MiniCPM 2.4B
model, they upcycled it to a 13.4
billion parameter model, and they got a
bunch of, you know, almost free wins
from doing that.
Um,
Qwen also, you know, when they did their
QwenMOE, initialized from their 1.8B
Qwen model, you know, they upcycled that
to a uh Qwen uh 1.5A 2.7B model, um and
they ended up with, you know, one of the
first and, you know, one of the very
high-performance uh models. It's one I
think one of the first larger-scale
upcycling successes. Of course, these
days, I don't think anyone's really
upcycling anymore because you don't
really train dense models and then
convert them. You might as well just
train your big, you know, hero run on a
MOE to start with, right? So, I don't
think we see this quite as much, but I
wanted to mention this because I think
it's an important thing to know in the
action space of mixture of experts
models.
Okay. So, the last thing I kind of want
to end with um
is I want to just walk us through the
DeepSeek models V1, V2, and V3. I think
there's kind of a lot to learn from the
evolution of DeepSeek models. And also,
if you're interested just in general
about MOEs or architecture design, I
would encourage that you read the
DeepSeek papers. I think they're very
well written. I think they have a lot of
details that are are worth digging into.
So, um the DeepSeek MOE architecture at
V1 um is is, you know, already actually
the prototype of a lot of different
modern MOEs. It's got the shared and
fine-grained expert structure. It uses
standard top-k routing with the
auxiliary loss balancing. I mean, in
some ways, I would say this is like the
prototypical like Platonic ideal of uh
of a MOE model. Um, DeepSeek MOE V2 kind
of just like scales this guy up, right?
So, you've got two shared experts, many
more fine-grained experts, um and you've
got this device routing um component,
and you've got a communication balancing
component. Both of these are essentially
adding auxiliary losses to optimize
systems. I think it's important to
realize that, you know, successful
language model training is not just
about, you know, deep learning, it's
also about really respecting your
system. So, that's right. So, DeepSeek
V2 is really a reflection, I think, of
this philosophy.
Um, and then um in DeepSeek MOE V3, you
know, they've still got the the shared
and fine-grained experts design, but
they've got sort of different ways of
doing balancing. They've got this
auxiliary they've got an aux loss free
ways of balancing the different um
experts. Um, and they've sort of
switched to using um sigmoid plus
softmax, which is a different way of
sort of weighting um their experts. But
really mostly similar.
Finally, since we're already here, we
might as well just walk through the rest
of DeepSeek MOE V3. They've got lots of
other cool things. I'm a big fan of of
how they think about systems. Um,
they've got multi-head latent attention,
where, you know, instead of doing QKV uh
sort of directly, what you're going to
do is you're going to represent them as
this as this lower-dimensional latency.
So, you have your hidden input, instead
of directly producing your Qs, Ks, and
Vs, you're going to first produce the C,
and then you're going to produce your
QKs and Vs as a function of that. And
that allows you to get sort of
significantly uh
improved savings. Instead of KV caching
all your Ks and Vs, I only need to store
these Cs, right? And the Cs are
hopefully lower dimensional, right? And
that's why it's called uh MLA, like
latent activation, because these Cs,
which are latent, are the KV cache
quantities that you need to save.
Um, the only complexity that you might
need to worry about is that this is
going to conflict with uh rope when you
you do sort of KV caching. Um, so you
have to be a little bit careful about
how, you know, you rotate different
dimensions and so on. Um, and sort of
the trick is you have non-latent
dimensions that encode positions, um but
I'm sort of not going to go into too
much more details about that. Finally,
something that I thought was a very cool
idea for MOE, I said DeepSeek MOE V3,
but hasn't caught on very much, is the
idea of MTP or multi-token prediction.
Instead of predicting one future token,
you predict multiple tokens um all at
once. That has sort of uh statistical
arguments for why that's a good idea.
Maybe it lets you predict the future a
little bit better. But also, there's
this nice systems argument that you kind
of now have a a speculative decoder
built in. Um, Percy will talk about that
when he talks about inference later. Um,
but it's a sort of a trick that you can
use to speed up your decoding from your
model.
Okay, I think we're roughly at time. So,
to put everything together, right? MOEs
are this kind of very clever idea to
take advantage of sparsity so that you
can have more parameters than you're
sort of paying for, right? So, you don't
pay for the the compute cost of all of
your parameters, but you are getting the
parameter benefits. Um,
you might initially think that this kind
of routing problem is very hard, but it
turns out that very simple things work
well even at scale. Um, and at this
point, it's kind of clear that MOEs are
here to stay. So, you should kind of
understand how they work and what they
are. Um,
thanks.